this week's 48 hours investigates the
case of a young texas woman who may have
been murdered because she resembled the
killer's
ex-girlfriend 24 year old college
student jackie vandegrift
her body was found the morning after she
met charles bryant at a bar
as police investigated they learned that
bryant had been stalking
another woman his ex-girlfriend and that
vandegriff may have been targeted
because he looked like her she looked
like her that ex-girlfriend
kaitlyn mathis spoke to cbs news senior
national correspondent jim axelrod
in her first tv interview
when jackie vander griff's body was
discovered in september of 2016
police soon uncovered video of a man she
was last seen with
at some college bars in denton texas
police didn't know his identity right
away but this woman
knew him very well he would always give
me flowers
always especially if he had something to
be sorry about caitlyn mathis had dated
charles bryant that past summer
and had recently broken things off he
was just trying to win me back
and i was just like nothing is gonna
work but bryant was not taking no for an
answer
in the weeks leading up to jackie's
death he kept showing up on caitlyn's
campus in denton
and was arrested three times you know
for sure was him
she had also filed a restraining order
against him
this history made bryant a good suspect
in jackie van der griff's case
but police didn't have enough evidence
to arrest him right away
but shortly after jackie's body was
found he tried to contact caitlyn again
which was a violation of that
restraining order
he was brought in for questioning yeah
that's crazy
i don't remember me at first bryant
denied knowing who jackie was
but texas ranger jim holland who
specializes in interviewing serial
killers
thought he might be able to get bryant
to confess
a lot of these people actually want to
tell you
they want to tell someone in the course
of a long interrogation
holland got brian to admit he had been
with jackie that night
but bryant wouldn't admit to murder
claiming she had died accidentally
after a consensual sexual encounter
are you just thinking this is a complete
and total lie
yeah it's total fabrication holland
believes brian did kill jackie
intentionally
and it was all triggered by his feelings
for caitlyn
in his mind he was seeking revenge on
his ex-girlfriend who had called the
police on him
i think that he really wanted to kill me
i think that he wanted me dead
oh boy you can see jim axelrod's report
the murder of jackie vandegriff on 48
hours tomorrow night at 10
9 central right here on cbs